[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait a minute hold on for a sec that
sounds a little
uh hollow there i can't put that on
there
so
there's a few things
that are a sign of things going terribly
then todd running between these two
rooms yes he doesn't run yes yeah so
fastly walking he runs he runs in the
back where the big german and uh dylan
are it's more of a skipping walk yeah
there's wilbon i could see him right
there on on a zoom call
oh there you go you couldn't see me no i
couldn't how are you doing got your
northwestern sweatshirt on looking good
yeah
um
i the freddie freeman story
is kind of fascinating here because
i'm not sure what happens as we move
forward he's playing well but if you're
a dodger teammate how do you feel about
freddie freeman with what has now
transpired in the last 48 hours i think
you feel like we think clayton kershaw
felt
but dan you know what i mean think of
all the times okay we know all the
details we know a lot of details here we
know how freddy felt because he's
freddie freeman because he's you know
mvp once you know removed
uh because the braves won we know all
these details how many times
does a player have regrets
about a signing
particularly when leaving a place where
he was a king
i think it happens way more than we know
because we know the details of this
um
it seems like oh my god i mean casey
close has been a a elite agent for a
long long time
and so all you have this confluence of
circumstance
that stances that put you in a position
where it looks like oh my god this is a
i don't think this is that rare at all
dan i think people have regrets all the
time about where they sign and they they
usually get over it usually in a
situation like freddie freeman's was
clear to me he didn't want to go
he didn't want to go but it's not the
first time that's happened either but
can you remember an athlete this
emotional
yeah
about but yeah i mean i remember come up
with like retiring you would see this
yeah i mean this was dick for meal like
like what's going on here
he didn't seem you know
did you did you question this in real
time like when you saw him
accept the ring go to the plate hug
whoever it was at first base at the time
did you say uh oh something's wrong here
no i
i just thought okay
during the lockout trying to get this
done
you know
it felt like that's where he belonged
that he loved the braves
and and he grew up in the organization
and that okay
he'll flirt with somebody but he's
coming back you know it's like chipper
jones was never leaving or you know dale
murphy eventually left and went to the
phillies but you know these guys it
feels like certain market tony gwynn
wasn't leaving they're serving guns
tony gwen cal ripken jr i mean eric
yes it was a surprise
but you know so few people stay forever
in one place now
that
you know it just seemed like okay
you know he he got his ring he won he's
fulfilled he's going to go on and do
this other thing yeah yeah
yeah i i don't think i gave much pause
to it other than
i thought of poo holes
because
the cardinals did the right thing let's
not embarrass him and not give him an
offer they got a hall of fame career out
of those 10 years and they probably said
go get him go go take you know take the
angels we we we would encourage you to
take that they were respectful
to him i thought the braves were doing
that let's be respectful
but go ahead i wouldn't turn down that
offer from the dodgers yeah and then we
find out the tick tock the behind the
scenes
of the entire thing i think i guess my
point
having covered
teams and people for a long time is
they're more of these than we think
where there's something that happens
in the background that's that that
shoves a person out a little bit more
than just oh let me jump
he's michael wilbon pardon the
interruption with uh tony kornheiser of
course you were at the nba finals and
the uh greatness of the golden state
warriors was on uh center stage there
is it still steph
like as steph goes because we look at
when athletes get a little bit older can
how long can steph be steph and what's
that mean for the warriors when he can't
be what he is right now well that's what
was really interesting about draymond
green saying they could win three of the
next four
you know
unlikely people get injured oh wait they
just had that people get old
other people coming up and other teams
become i mean young studs are trying to
take you out
all the time
and that's going to happen
to the warriors if they don't just
retire on their own so
do i think they can do this again next
year yes absolutely
absolutely i think they're primed for it
when steve kerr said you usually better
the second year dan he was right on the
money i mean to me the greatest balls
team of all time was the second one not
the one that won
73 games 72 games but the team
that
horace grant before dennis robin got
there and horrors grant john paxton they
beat i think portland that was the
greatest bulls team that was the truly
the second team not just the second of
the two three petes but the second one
so i think the warriors have that in
them but does it last forever no but
nobody ever learns that
and not in our business either i mean
i understand athletes feeling this way
that's what they're supposed to do
they better have that irrational
confidence that borders on delusion
but when people in our business just buy
into it
and start saying stupid stuff and
automatically come up with a question it
just makes me angry and i want to call
every show that i see that's happening
and say you're an idiot stop being an
idiot study sports study the history of
sports study the history of any sport
and you don't just get people winning
and bunch i know the nba and nhl have
more
multiples they have more repeaters
but they don't just go you know eight in
ten years or whatever the suggestions
are
and it's not so easy just oh yeah
they're going to win next year and the
odds makers and the who's favored
all of this hype makes me angry now i'm
i'm old dan you know this
and i get angry at the suggestion that
it's so easy to win championships i'm
not saying draymond green saying that
because he didn't say that do you have a
lawn in arizona for people to get off of
no i know there's no grill you don't
want to make grass
no
no real grass get off my rocks you know
off my dry straw whatever it is but do
you think you helped usher in the hot
takes you and tony no no because we
don't because we don't do that
no
i tell people when they say something to
me about that's a great question i say
no i don't have a hot take i have an
opinion which is layered yeah it's
usually nuanced it may also be
yeah i kind of agree with part of that
and i don't have hot takes and i
actually hate them
but it feels like though mike your
answers are bite-sized portions
therefore it it's almost presented in a
hot take fashion because you and tony
split two minutes on a topic
yeah but two minutes are hot takes a lot
shorter
i don't even know i'm not a hot take guy
i got no hot takes coming out of the
oven mike i just don't when people say
you don't have hot takes i go you know
what how about just an opinion
maybe i there are times when i go i
don't know
yes
yes or how about this
yeah the other guy's right
you know which
i mean tony and i disagree a lot less
than people think we do
we're loud and getting there yeah but
but it's less disagreement but no i
don't because they're too many times
that over time i may also change or move
that position a little bit based on
circumstances
so no i i hot takes ah
um nba free agency the knicks are back
they got jalen brunson
no they're not
and so right now i'm in chicago right
now where jalen brunson grew up and
played at a high school
where you know friends of the family are
i love jaylen brunson jaylen brunson has
self-made more than any really really
really good nba player
any player of his statue
this kid did not have nba written all
over him at all even though his dad as
we know played in the league
but dan
he's not they're gonna they're gonna put
pressure on this kid this signing this
circumstance the way it went down it's
gonna put pressure on jalen brunson he
does not deserve is gonna try to make
something of him that he is not he's a
terrific nba player but look at what
happened with julius randle that man
julius randle second team all nba and
then this last season they turned on him
and i worry that they're gonna they're
gonna look at jalen brunson maybe for
one of the few times they've seen him
they're like wait we spent 27 million
dollars a year on this and he's not
clyde frazier yeah
no
and
i feel i feel for him already and love
him love him don't love the circumstance
he's in dan no no i and by the way he's
not a one
i'm not even sure he's a real two
i think that he he's a he's part of an
ensemble and you'd love to have him and
you can win with him but not with him
dragging a team like the knicks
the team with more pressure usually than
anybody to be something that they're not
i i worry for him he's a great kid
michael great to talk to you as always
and uh hope you're doing well thanks for
joining me no hot takes now don't give
in to that no no no no
i give luke warm takes
like a like a nice warm bath mike i no
no hot ticks no hot
that's michael wilbon or as steve
spurrier referred to him wilbon